I think we've got time for one more
quick one now I think I'm gonna go to
the 585 area code and I have a suspicion
about who this might be we'll see if I'm
vindicated five eight five who's this
Wow
five eight five go ahead hi this is
Tyler okay Tyler I'm not disappointed
that it's you but I thought it could
have been someone else but go ahead
Tyler oh sorry you never think I'm from
the same the same city that he goes to
about hi my question is basically what
do you think is trumps like end game for
his trade war on China because today
China's imposing like new yeah hunter
tariffs to the United States and Trump
made a tweet today basically like like
he's denying that there's a trade war
and he's trying to say that like the
trade war actually and like ended years
ago on her pour of like leadership so
he's like denying it faithfully he had
Trump has no clue how it will happen but
his vision for our end is being the
winner right he wants to be the winner
he's the guy who after Obama failed and
who everybody else failed he finally got
China over a barrel and got them to
start quote treating us fairly and stop
stealing intellectual property and he he
wants to be the winner that everybody
Pat's on the back and says you did it
you did it and nobody else was able to
the problem is that the it's like very
difficult to actually make that happen
by escalating a trade war so you know if
you if the question is how will it
happen it's not going to but if the
question is what's Trump's vision for
the end it's him being declared the
winner of just this masterful gaming of
China through his tariffs and who knows
whatever else tweets I guess tariffs and
tweets okay
so basically you're saying he's using
like the entire situation just he's
exploiting it for his own ego it's not
so much that he's exploiting it
for his own ego he probably genuinely
thinks that he can do this for the
betterment of the economy he just
doesn't know anything about economics or
trade so it makes it difficult to
actually pull off you know what I mean
yeah so basically like everything outfit
exactly you can basically apply the same
analysis yeah thanks for the call really
appreciate it we're going to go to a
break if you're on hold we will continue
taking calls shortly for our YouTube
channel so don't hang up we will be
right back after this